[Applause]
i just want to point this out
al is on super defense mode and i tried
to get it out before the podcast i tried
to sit down with him because
i was posting pictures on his instagram
live
this weekend about him on a boat right
now
if you're new to this podcast al's the
you know he doesn't have sex with black
women that's one thing that is
100 true not true al said how does not
have sex with coming from a comedian
i being offensive today or is everybody
just a little bit more sensitive
al does not have sex with black women
this is this is something and you were
doing this before you made it
which is very good you know my
ex-girlfriend was black what are you
talking about yeah but that was way back
in day and then you knew this is the
trill you know how jp morgan
made his wife sign a prenup when he had
fifteen dollars in his pocket it was
like he knew he was gonna make it
and he's like this [ __ ] can't get half
that's how you were you're like listen
i'm gonna be a black celebrity
so i'm gonna stop [ __ ] black women
now you're
jp morgan you're ready chasing all the
black [ __ ] out of your life
i'm true rich enough yet so i don't
deserve to be with a beautiful black
queen
oh so now you're with the white girls
dude just now getting it out of here so
you admit that your girl's wife
that's all you said that's all i wanted
for you to admit it you said girl's
plural
bro i heard plural stop it out you're
wearing one of her tote bags as a shirt
[Applause]
cape cod no more done your legs nice
listen
thick today yo all right i was working
legs
i was doing some squats i was doing some
hamstrings you know what i mean
i saw perky hey yes
you think you're out you're not out okay
remember that boat pick that the
giants did remember it was all like the
recycling oh yeah
yeah right al did the same pick only it
was just
women that those giants would [ __ ]
with all types of people all black guys
right no yeah well i know where this is
going hold on no
how it ends and the [ __ ] just started
yeah i know this is what's happening
this is good
okay do you want to predict where it
goes and then i talked about
black guys he's already wrong on this
okay how many white guys one white guy
where what type of white was he white
white from where you're
he got y'all on the boat he the captain
oh actually that makes two because the
captain was right too there we go boom
yes let's go
[Applause]
you're like yo get in the picture so we
got some diversity it looks like we
stole white women
all right so it's a bunch of black dudes
right there's
three black dudes two spanish dudes two
white dudes right
yep it looked like it was tons of black
dudes
i mean hey right summertime now are you
spanish what does that mean
summertime you're spanish you're spanish
i'm spanish
in that picture you're spanish or black
i mean it's late in the summer i would
say i'm more so black you're black okay
now of how many full black women were on
that boat
two did they come with that right
there's a lie
there's two that right there is a lie
out there there is one
so here's the thing there's one side
don't get your corporate owl voice on
bro did you see him put his corporate
alex's voice on i said he used to [ __ ]
all these white girls
no you're not on a boat no more dogs
relax you know how
[ __ ] we're a life preserver what do
you guys have
so what is this shirt don't know why so
we can see your shirt out can you just
let everybody see it
this shirt i don't know bro she looks
like it goes around miss cleo's head so
she can make psychic predictions
i predict some white imported babies
this weekend
yeah it's not you it's not you it could
be anybody oh
for real no no tell us keep up your
[ __ ] keep your [ __ ] go you know
how
shirt guys i hate his shirt so goddamn
much
i'm not gonna lie i did love it when i
first saw it
that [ __ ] i hate this right now
it's disgusting
great [ __ ] face
is fantastic i mean it's summer
appropriate the whole thing
it goes with the rolly the little purple
in the shirt oh there we go
yeah thank you well mark wants to get it
mark goes together
there's someone sweat from being in the
spin cycle
actual drip drops off your forehead
that's crazy but it's okay okay
go how are you saying this go okay
so you know how you guys have while you
talk i'm just thinking of things to make
fun of you
so
yeah yes and they would love that shirt
and you
choose to hide their identity on your
social media i'll be honest
right now my girl's black exactly
and you don't show her because you're
protecting her and i protected all the
black women that are on the boat that's
why you don't see them in the photos
bang whoo that was hard
i don't care if you give me something
okay that was hard first of all i just
want to clarify in case my girl is
listening
i know you're not black babe but you got
the
wagon but
wow i think that all he was thinking
about was insults and
i gotta apologize
i really just thought that y'all were
gonna laugh at me saying my girl is
black
but y'all went with it you're like oh no
he's really trying to hide her identity
they've seen her on wow it's wasabi no
no
all right so you're not hiding the black
girls no
no we're protecting them no you're not
you yeah you i think you protect the
white girls too
nah not right i think you do no not
really i think you do i think you do
like really
gonna
you know what i agree with you al that's
a great point that you're making because
all lives do matter
what alex media is saying is that all
lives
matter when it comes to women wow do all
lives matter when it comes to women
how you guys say that son al do they nah
there's a hierarchy
there's a hierarchy of lives why would
you go that direction
this guy is lost right now he's [ __ ]
lost some when you spin it it's hard to
find the reason
there ain't no compass in that moment up
which way's down bro
like your [ __ ] shirt bro dude how do
you find a way to put that on
i was weak it was weak you're right
dude i was on a roll bro all right
anyway
okay so
chicago
all right for real though ow in all
seriousness
we need to protect women that's true
that's a very true statement we do need
to protect women yes
okay um
i think it's it breaks my heart that you
cannot admit that you just have an
affinity for white ladies
it's not true you don't like white women
at all i like all women
that's you know who says that i just say
that guys who like white women
hmm yo you know what's interesting is if
you're black and you like white women
you gotta be like i love all women
yeah if you're black you love black
women you just go i love black women
yeah
and then like mad repos yeah
that is interesting you have to admit
you love all you can't spell yo i like
white women
yeah yo yo
i would say watch this watch this no no
no but you know my you've met
come on all right look here's what i'm
saying is
yo yo you cannot this is actually
interesting
you cannot nobody
can admit that they like white women
nobody can say you know what i just like
white women you could say
i love latinas you can say i love asian
chicks
you can say i love black women if
anybody goes i love whitewater if you're
black
you're a sellout if you're white they're
like yo you're racist
if you're indian you're a sellout if
you're asian yourself if you're asian
you're a
is isn't it interesting white women are
not allowed to be loved
that's [ __ ] up for the same reason you
can't have white pride
for the same reason well why white
people can't have white pride
but why other people can't have white
pride that wouldn't make any sense
now here's the thing you can't have
white pride that's what if you say it's
confetti
that's a different discussion because
white isn't a culture so to say like you
can have italian pride you have polish
pride you can have russian pride
right nobody would push back on that but
you could say you like russian women
i think if you're like yo i only like
russian women
i don't think people i don't think
people i think it's still not still
weird no but
it's less weird he brings up a good
point what is less
weird what if he presented as a fetish
it's still a little weird but oh it's a
fetish it's a thing he's into so white
women got to be a kink
yes yes i said pink yes
[Music]
not like my other fetish
no seriously that's interesting so if
white women are your
fetish would you allow an indian guy to
say i have a white woman
fetish i feel like you'd be like okay
whatever all right that's a little i
guess that's his thing
yeah i mean i feet who am i to judge
what i mean like that's
everybody got a fetish his fetish
happens to be
white women also now that you said the
thing about feet interesting thing to
point out
apparently the sexual receptors in your
brain are located
right next to this [ __ ] already it's
still yeah you're saying it like you
learned it you brought it up two weeks
ago if i keep saying it
if i keep saying it everyone will
believe it everybody will help can i get
through it
real quick can i just say it i swear to
you i heard this in my mcat class from
we had like uh swear to god we had a
med school teacher and i wasn't open
about the fact that i liked feet but it
made me feel very comfortable at the
time i was like oh okay
word it's not completely weird she said
this exact thing
what do you mean she said this exactly
she said whatever the the receptors in
the brain
would you like me to finish that yeah
finish it okay
your brain is mapped your physiology is
mapped in your brain okay that's why
like
you know you can poke certain parts of
the brain you feel them on different
parts of your body
and that's right next to the sexual
pleasure center is right next to the
feet one and sometimes they get a little
bit mixed
it actually means you're evolved
do you know that why does it mean you're
evolving you [ __ ] amphibians don't
call me an amphibian
i am i'm one step uh heavier no
well why is it advising me you're more
evolved it's because your brain is being
squashed that means it's so big
here's the thing there's a
listen your skull is only as big as your
skull you probably didn't know that
[ __ ] [ __ ] over here okay
right so look right your skull is always
your skull is
your brain was like oh i'm just going to
be this big but then you got so
smart it decided to grow even within
your skull
yeah and then it mashed the pleasure
pleasure sensor and the feet sensor
together
now you have a foot fetish maybe i got
the biggest brain because the white girl
center is probably way back here
all the way so how brain is proudly
[ __ ] enormous
bro that's true dude do you think black
people have the biggest brains
why are you laughing sword they don't
like white women no
no
that's a [ __ ] up thing no but do you
think black people have the biggest
brains like
because they got the biggest a lot of
things i know i'm thinking because
there's not even like room for their
hair to be straight
right like it's all squished up and then
it comes out so curved there's so much
brain
there's so much brain yo y'all might
have the biggest brains bro
that's a big brain thing of you to say
so you think i
you have to have a certain
oh [ __ ] bro